this episode of shots of awe is brought
to you by Kay Jewelers every kiss begins
with Kay
you know when people talk about the
desire for ethics when we talk about
chasing happiness I think what they're
ultimately talking about is chasing
novelty because it's only the new that
awakens the mind that fully engages us
with the world
become anthropologists in the new
environment we transcend the banality
and boredom and the trivialities of the
everyday normally we trivialize
ourselves with triviality when we are
gorged by a new experience all of a
sudden become alive we feel as children
we got raptured and we're always chasing
that like we want happiness and any
other things who help you actually
understood what we were saying when we
say oh I just want to be happy I just
want to be happy what you mean is you
want to continue to explore what did you
learn you want to continue to discover
novel lands new landscapes of mind of
perception of thoughts like this is what
you can't stop learning we can never
stop seeking I think that you know we'll
settle down through these routines and
then we wonder why we're miserable and I
think it's ultimately because happiness
lives in the space of novelty
you